alors je vous propose de regarder ma
faim et documents que je suis allé
tourner à la maternité port royal et qui
va permettre de voir d'abord ce qu'est
une chaise d'accouchement comment se
passent les choses qu'ils allaient le
mois dernier et vous verrez que ces
chaises ressemble parfois des tables
d'accouchement parfois nous voici audrey
3 kg une petite fille bien vive né dans
la nuit du 27 au 28 octobre à la
maternité port royal
un événement banal mais un accouchement
cependant comme on n'en voit pas encore
tous les jours il s'est fait sur les
nouvelles chaises d'accouchement que
commence tout juste à essayer un peu
partout en france les maternités
publiques et privées pour nous deux
sages-femmes sont la démonstration
l'idée et d'accoucher en position ou
obliques sinon à 6 mais pas à la façon
des écologistes pas accroupi sur le sol
en fa mineur op
mais sur une table d'accouchement
orientable en présence d'une équipe
médicale dans des services traditionnels
la position de départ est allongée et
comme à l'habitude la future mère place
ses pieds dans les étriers lorsque le
moment de la descente de l'enfant est
proche
on place la mer en position oblique plus
ou moins six selon les nécessités la
femme va pouvoir effectuer les pousser
en cédant des étriers des accoudoirs et
des poignets bref en cédant des pieds et
des mains
ici la démonstration permet de voir les
différentes positions que vous reprendre
l'achève jusqu'à la position quasi
assises on pourrait aussi la ramener en
table coucher si le besoin s'en faisait
sentir
tout cela c'est la théorie voici
maintenant la pratique la naissance
d'audrey avec cette chaise qui il faut
le préciser n'était allé c'est dans
l'établissement que depuis quinze jours
la sage femme qui va procéder s'en
servaient pour la deuxième fois ce qui
explique un manque d'audace dans
l'inclinaison du siège sécurité avant
tout le père assisté à l'accouchement
la femme n'était plus coucher mais
malgré tout encore trait oblique les
doigts de pieds crispé témoigne
discrètement mais fermement des poussées
douloureuses
la jeune femme n'avait pas souhaité
l'anesthésié péridurale on vérifie une
dernière fois que tout va bien à 3h30 du
matin le bébé montrer sa tête une
intervention pour couper le cordon et
audrey se retrouvent une seconde sur le
ventre de sa mère l'accouchement au
blick s'est bien passée et là nous avons
affaire au suite logique de
l'accouchement ordinaire dans la détente
le bébé est resté un peu avec sa mère
puis il est nettoyé
il va être maintenant réchauffer en
couveuse comme le sont très souvent les
bébés normaux après n'importe canoë sens
pendant ce temps la mer nous dira
qu'elle a trouvé l'accouchement
inconfortable mais c'était son premier
né et la sage femme dira qu'il est trop
tôt pour en être sûr
mais que leur groupe a eu en quinze
jours déjà la pression que la durée du
travail été raccourci par l'effet de la
pesanteur
audrey s'est bien moqué de la technique
pendant le temps nous étions là elle a
fait plus de trois fois le tour de sa
couveuse témoignant d'une très très
belle vitalité
[Musique]